you personally thank you very much for
clicking on my video i love you for that
and before we get started i want to give
some love to the sponsor of this video
this video is brought to you by nordvpn
a lot of what we do how we work who we
are is online that means there's a lot
of information that is you that's on the
internet that those with ill intent can
steal and use to their own nefarious end
so it's more important than ever to
protect your information thus protect
you nordvpn's a vpn service that does
just that but it doesn't just stop there
we're all movie buffs entertainment
buffs let's say you're overseas oh they
don't have my favorite show here it's
fine you don't have to miss it you can
change your virtual location with one
click you can explore the world and
catch your favorite shows you don't got
to choose you can choose between over 5
100 servers in 60 countries you got to
love those options and nord has a 30 day
money back guarantee it's risk free you
know i love that peace of mind so click
the link below go to
nordvpn.com get yourself a two-year
subscription plus one additional month
with a huge discount and thank you once
again to nordvpn for sponsoring this
video i do appreciate it and now
video game to movie adaptations those
are always always a sure thing
[Music]
so uncharted is a film adaptation of the
beloved video game franchise uncharted
the uncharted games are one of those
scenarios where the games get a lot of
praise and they're absolutely deserving
of all that praise the one caveat the
thing i can say is the first game shows
a bit of its age
other than that so in this film
adaptation we have tom holland as nathan
drake and mark wahlberg is sully okay
come on and this is the story of how
they meet though we saw a glimpse of
that in the third game and now they're
on their first adventure together to
find the lost gold of magellan as a fan
of the games let's go into this movie
like okay it's not gonna be as good as
the games but you know maybe we can have
some fun and some fun is in here but as
for the casting tom holland is nathan
drake
it's
i i never fully bought him as nathan
drake even young nathan drake i love tom
holland as much as the next person i
think he's great but it never felt like
someone out there was like oh tom
holland because we found the best nathan
drake possible it felt like all right
tom holland's a superstar and it was
before spider-man no way home
owned [ __ ] face in the box office
that's right tom holland great we have
him in the movie fantastic and then it
feels like the rest of the movie was
molded around that one casting decision
don't know i wasn't in the room just
telling you how it feels it feels like
all right tom holland great he's a bit
young
all right we'll just make everyone young
and we'll make it an origin story a
prequel well not really it's not really
linked to the games it's just kind of an
origin story all right we'll have young
chloe frazier and younger sully in which
my counter argument would be well the
characters in the uncharted series are
far more interesting when they're in
their 30s than their 20s i mean seeing
it as an origin story i don't know that
tom hall and nathan drake would grow to
be this person this character who has
the biggest body count of any video game
character on earth don't know what tom
holland drake would snap a neck
i snapped a lot of necks in those games
mark wahlberg being cast as sully was
absolutely proof that the dare program
was a failure because someone out there
was high as [ __ ] when they made that
call having a young sully sure
mark wahlberg doesn't look like sully
sound like sully or act like sully i'm
gonna be like
i'm going down there without some
firepower go talk to that rudd merchant
we just passed i mean guns bullets and
[ __ ] he's not really a rug merchant ah
that's what i'm talking about i will say
one of the standouts in this movie was
antonio banderas he captures the spirit
of what an uncharted villain would be
he's not based on an uncharted villain
that came before him but you look at
this guy you're like you would be an
uncharted villain i thought antonio
banderas in this movie was great as for
the action in this movie entertaining
yes plausible no ridiculous yep cgi of
course but there was entertainment there
the best action sequence in this movie i
think is a scene on the plane but it was
also awesome in the game and better in
the game so i'll just play it in the
game and that's what this movie runs
into it's the point i brought up in my
review of the new resident evil movie
and the point i brought up was a lot of
these video games these days fulfill
that cinematic experience in fact more
so and better than a movie can because
you are playing through it you're not
just watching it you're a part of it so
having a video game to film adaptation
for these action games isn't as
necessary as it once was being in the
plane when it all starts going to [ __ ]
and the back opens up cargo and people
just start getting blown out the back
including you while you are a part of it
experiencing it is way more intense than
tom holland doing it on a green screen i
will say this
on the plane there's this thing that
happens in the plane where i was like
well the movie is just
fundamentally worse now luckily not long
after that you're in the last act of the
movie in which this movie goes balls
crazy ridiculous it's like it doesn't
even care yeah you're looking for
plausibility out of here with that [ __ ]
we are just cg eyeing the most
impossible past implausible zero [ __ ]
given cgi action fest you could possibly
think of and they commit to it credit to
that i can't say i didn't have fun with
that ridiculous [ __ ] just in a world
where uncharted is a tentpole franchise
of action games i think of
quintessential game franchise of action
adventure exploring i will mentally go
to uncharted this movie's fine but
pretty indistinguishable from any other
adventure movie out there think of an
adventure movie where people explore and
they're looking for a treasure this and
that not one of the ones that really
stands out we were like whoa that was
surprisingly good but one of the ones
where you're like okay that happens
another one of those
this uncharted movie doesn't feel much
different than those you remember that
fan film that uncharted fan film that
had nathan fillion as nathan drake that
feels more like uncharted than this
uncharted movie this uncharted movie
feels like
muppet babies like the muppet babies
version of uncharted you know where you
have the grown-up adult or otherwise
seasoned versions of the characters and
then because well it's cool to show
younger versions of those characters
will you make that too okay nanny again
don't hate this uncharted movie but if
you go into this movie as an uncharted
fan i feel like you're going to find it
lacking who knows maybe it'll be a
better time if you're drunk yeah this is
the hard way i was talking about anyhow
the uncharted movie have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]
you